die provokation denn überhaupt nicht
tragen zu bauen ihn zähler drücken damit
beginnen die allerdings unter vier
minister bondi innerhalb der top picks
ausgehalten edition ist nicht der kurzen
pass und alles alles
münchen sollen es bei 500 jugendliche in
die redaktionsräume der bild zeitung und
verwüsteten sie der sds kündigte an er
wolle die auslieferung von zeitungen des
verlags hause springer tochter anschlag
erschüttert die bundesrepublik auf dem
kurfürstendamm
die letzten zeugnisse des attentats sein
opfer
rudi dutschke führt zu den schwersten
studentenunruhen in der bundesrepublik
mit wasserwerfern tränengas und
schlagstöcken die polizei gegen die
demonstranten vor es gilt erstmal ein
bewusstsein des missstandes zu schaffen
jetzt nicht gleich zu fragen gibt doch
die antwort ein dutzend keine antwort
geben das wäre genau wider die das wäre
das wäre genau das wäre genau die
manipulative anfang die nicht zu geben
bereit bin
[Applaus]
[Musik]